well not actually not actually
protesting they decided when the school
district came up with this sort of plan
to thwart desegregation efforts
so-called freedom of choice plan where
whites were supposed to choose white
schools and blacks would choose black
schools they decided to send me to the
white school instead of choosing the
neighborhood black school so they were
not protesters in the sense that they
were out you know doing anything as a
matter of fact the agreement was that my
parents would not you know make a big
deal about it and the school district
would make a big deal about it and they
would I would just go and everything
would be as normal as possible under the
circumstances I was there by myself it
was pretty tough at first there were
people who sort of when I went out of
their way kids you know how kids are
anybody who's different in a way a lot
of times there's some kids who fixate on
that but there were a few who I guess
whose parents told them you know to make
sure that they played with me but by far
it was it was a very tough situation the
teachers were fine they were wonderful
but it was a very tense moment my mother
said at one point that I broke out in
hives I don't remember that but it was
certainly a stress reaction I think to
what was going on
well I think it made me think at a very
early age about race I think lots of
black people in the south during that
time period did this is the mid-60s
thought about race but I I was very
conscious of there being some sort of
movement in the world that something was
changing in the world because i was at
this school and I was sort of on display
delegations of people would come by and
stand in the doorway and sort of look
inside to see this you know big
experiment that you know this one black
person in the room full of whites so I
had a sense of well mission is to
messianic but a sense that there was a
purpose and that black people were going
somewhere I mean from a very early age
that there was someplace to go that
there was something that was wrong that
had to be changed so I started thinking
about those things pretty early on this
kind of forced me into that